Speaker 1: Why don't we go
next to Kang from Arkansas?
Am I pronouncing that correctly? It's Kang.
Speaker 3: Oh, yes. Yes, you are. Definitely.
Speaker 1: Well, welcome.
Speaker 3: Welcome. I'm a
big fan of yours. I've been a big fan of yours
for, like, 20 years. Amazing. I'm even talking
to you. I'm kind of overwhelmed.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Well,
you're doing great so far.
Speaker 3: Okay. Thank you so much.
I'm a progressive in Arkansas, which,
you know, Arkansas is super MAGA,
super conservative. But that has
nothing to do with my question. But
basically, do you think you'll ever get
a spot in any of the mainstream news
organizations like CNN, MSNBC, etc.?
Speaker 1: Oh, I don't I mean,
I'm not even looking for that. I don't know.
Probably not. I don't I don't think so. I can't
imagine they'd be interested in me. But I like
working for myself and setting my own schedule and
taking vacation when I want and not having,
you know, 12 bosses and editors and stuff like
that. So I'm not even looking for that.
Speaker 3: Well, what if there was like,
do you remember Current TV with Keith OLBERMANN
and. Yes, I do know that if there was ever a
progressive station, like in the mainstream in the
United States, would you ever consider having a
slot like you're keeping your business the way it
is, David Pakman channel, but also having your own
hour, a 30 minute long TV show on
some sort of mainstream network? Sure.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen,
I consider all proposals.
So certainly if someone brings me
a proposal, I would consider it.
Speaker 3: I agree because I would love to see
you on TV. I think you're a great influence to
the American political sphere, and I wish
you the best of luck in everything you have
going in the future. And I wish to see you
debate Ben SHAPIRO or Steven Crowder or any
of those stupid right wingers eventually.
Speaker 1: Well, thank you. And remember,
we are on satellite TV every night on
DirecTV and Dish Network on free speech TV.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I watch you on free speech
TV. Very much. Oh, nice. Yeah. Well, thank
you for taking my call. I really appreciate it.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you. There's Hank
from Arkansas. Very, very powerful
declaration about television.